We are going to jump into this topic of
how
to be perfect, what is perfection before
God, and how perfect is perfect enough.
We've had several questions from people
um lots of
myself included. I've grown up in a
certain way in the Christian church,
always asking, "How do I actually make
it?" And most of us are asking that in
general. We know the time is coming
where
the second coming of Christ is going to
be upon us very soon, and we all want to
be able to make it, not because we just
want to be there, but how are we going
to be there because we truly
made it. Like, not just earned it
because we did what was right, but
because we are known by the Father, as
he says,
Jesus can come have others approach him,
and they will say, "I did all this stuff
in your name. I spoke, I cast out demons
in your name, I healed the sick in your
name." And he said, "I don't know you."
Um so, on this topic,
um we need to talk about it because it
can
haunt you. Like, am I seriously going to
be ready for the day that the Lord
appears in the clouds, or am I not?
And um like I said, I didn't grow up
always thinking that way, but some
people were always telling me, "You got
to be perfect. You have to be perfect
when he comes. You have to be so ready."
And did you confess all your sins? Is
there something
When people hear the word perfection,
they jump into
a heavy weight
that immediately pushes them into
thinking,
"Did I confess everything in my life?
Did I miss something? Can I ever measure
up
to God's standards?"
So, if that's you and you're just
interested,
listen up, because
there's some good news.
But,
when I say good news, it can also feel
like when you are being
told that have to be perfect,
that it's not actually good news.
It starts to feel like a checklist that
you can never finish.
Yet, as we know in the Bible, Jesus said
that we are to be perfect just as our
Father in heaven is perfect.
And I believe that. We are to be,
but the details
are key.
And that's what we're going to be
getting into.
So, here's the truth we have to come
back to.
I really need people to hear this part.
Because
the idea that you need to go back and
dig through your life confessing every
single forgotten thought, action, every
mistake, every wrong motive in your
life.
Like your salvation is hanging on
whether you remember everything or not.
First of all, God knows that as faulty
human beings, we have flawed memories as
well.
Yes, we need to confess our sins before
him
to be forgiven,
and should do this anytime that we sin,
but our salvation alone doesn't hang on
that.
And then on top of it, people start
adding layers. Have you noticed
when you're around someone kind of
really zealous for their faith, they can
start adding extra expectations and
rules as to how you're supposed to live
that faith out.
Extra books,
extra rules, and extra standards
that go beyond what scripture actually
tells us.
It becomes quite weighty.
And before you know it, you're not just
following Christ's
example or Christ anymore. You're trying
to live up to people's pressure,
expectations,
their books,
their preachers, and their prophets.
That's a problem.
You're trying to meet their version of
what perfection looks like then.
But God already defines what that means
to him, and he's the one you have to
actually
please.
And not in a bad way, but you have to be
perfect
by his standards,
and not what others want.
And I'm going to get personal right now,
but even in ministry, working as we do,
Mikey and I,
there are other ministry leaders, there
are other
church members, brothers and sisters in
Christ, who come up to you, and they
share certain ideas,
and they want you all of a sudden to
meet or live up to those expectations
that you find yourself
not also holding, perhaps.
But they will not let you live it down.
They're putting it on you.
As it were, a chain they're wrapping
around you and making you have to live
up to while you're at least in their
>> [laughter]
>> presence.
And it's very hard. You find yourself
sometimes not realizing how weighed down
you feel during the day trying to meet
everyone else's expectations of what a
good Christian is.
Meanwhile, you realize,
I need to get back to what Christ says
and what the Bible says, because
that's what really matters.
And that is the only thing that really
matters.
Now,
there are certain examples, which I will
get into right here.
Um
Mikey put it in the comments. It's
Genesis 6:9.
It says, "These are the generations of
Noah. Noah was a just man and perfect in
his generations, and Noah walked with
God."
All right? Enoch also walked with God
also.
Um
I can't claim Was he considered perfect?
I'm not sure.
But, we have some really good examples.
I'm not saying there aren't people who
in the Bible were directly called
perfect. Oh, here's another one.
1 Kings 15:14.
But the high places were not removed.
Nevertheless, Asa's heart was perfect
with the Lord all his days.
Okay.
So, I'm not going to get into all the
examples, but I am going to continue to
explain to you what
what God really has for us
when he wants us to meet his standards
and be in heaven with him. What is his
perfection, his standard of perfection,
look like?
How perfect is perfect enough for God?
The thing is, if the standard is that
you must reach a state of absolute
flawless perfection before Christ
returns,
that's crushing.
Because
for those who have been in the church,
like I was explaining in myself, we've
been trying to meet these expectations.
Maybe you're new and you just started to
try to meet these expectations, but
we have been heaped up with burdens from
other people, like I was just
explaining.
And usually from them just being
judgmental of one another, and exacting
of how each other should live.
The problem with that is your focus,
like I said, is not on what the Bible
says and what Christ wants,
and that's where you kind of should draw
a circle around what I just said. The
focus is shifted away from Christ.
And onto ourselves,
trying to do works.
Yes, we need Christ every step of the
way, because we are flawed and we can't
do anything in our own strength, and we
need to ask for his strength daily to do
what he wants us to do.
However,
we don't need to be beating ourselves up
constantly to do this.
We need to resist the devil,
follow God's word in obedience, trust
and believe, and the rest will be
covered by him.
Now,
for those who are going to say, "Oh,
okay. So, I heard God's word. I
understand he gives his free gift of
perfection
or salvation to people, and that's all I
need. Like, I'm good."
Well, no, not exactly.
Again, we got to get into the details.
So, let's take a look.
This is the verse I have for you right
now that I'd like to focus on. It's
James 1:22.
It says, "But ye be doers of the word,
and not hearers only, deceiving your own
selves."
So, this pertains exactly to
those who I've I've met several of
different backgrounds and denominations
who say that you basically once saved,
always saved. Once you accept that free
gift from Christ,
you are going to have salvation. You
will be in the kingdom.
And unfortunately, that is not true.
You can actually lose your salvation by
your choices.
And
the thing is is you have your life line
up. That's why it says be doers of the
word. Your life has to line up
with
your Christian walk. If you're still
drinking, if you're still cussing, if
you are still lying, cheating,
in adultery, um have addictions in your
life,
many other things the Bible says not to
do,
you are
not having a life that is fully lined up
with what Christ
says doers of the word are.
And that does make you deceiving
yourself as the verse say says.
So,
again,
we do have a work to do in our life,
which I'm going to explain.
But there are some legal terms we have
to understand first.
The real truth is so much simpler and so
much more powerful.
I need you to listen up cuz it's fine
details here. We're splitting hairs.
Perfection,
now listen,
perfection was never something you were
actually meant to manufacture
of yourself.
Okay?
It's never something you were meant to
manufacture
of yourself.
It was given. This is where I do agree
that it is a
gift. Christ lived the perfect life that
you couldn't live.
That is true.
And that perfection is credited to you.
And here's
the exact details that the book
His Robe or Mine really helped me see,
and I really recommend that you read it.
It started setting me free of some of
these deceptions we get while we're in
the church being told you have to do
this, you have to do that, you have to
do that.
You should read the book.
But it says
I might paraphrase some, but it says we
are all given a measure of faith
enough to reach out to Christ like the
father with the demon-possessed son did.
Faith simply opens the door for Christ
to help us
according to our need
and his glory.
Jesus is not only the author but the
perfector and finisher of our faith.
Hebrews 12:2.
And just to prove that, I will look it
up.
But it's such a good verse
and we need to keep that in mind.
Hebrews 12:2.
All right.
It states it this way, the full verse,
"Looking unto Jesus, the author and
finisher of our faith, who for the joy
that was set before him endured the
cross,
despising the shame, and is set down at
the right hand
of the throne of God."
All right.
So, when we think of that,
we need to remember
that's where it comes from.
We are given a measure of faith
according to our need and his glory, and
he is the finisher and perfector of our
faith.
So, he works out in us, but that does
not mean that we are off the hook. Like
I said, we have to have a life that
shows up here.
Again,
there's some more details we're missing.
We all need sanctification and
justification in our life.
The process of justification is a legal
one.
One, we need someone justified
and qualified
to do the legal work
to do for us, right?
Jesus is the only one
who is qualified to do our legal work
in the realms and
throne of heaven.
And so, we need to rely on him.
And on the cross of Calvary, he paid the
redemption price
of the entire race.
And thus, he gained the right to rescue
the captives from the grasp of the
deceiver, Satan.
All right, so that's how it works. He
got that right to free all of humanity,
the entire race, from Satan
by being the perfect life that we need
in place.
Okay? I'm getting a little bit ahead of
myself cuz this is good. Again,
get into the nitty-gritty details
because it next says, "By his dying on
the cross,
he earned the right to become our
attorney in the Father's presence."
Justification, this is a direct quote
from the book, "Justification being
legal work can only deal with our legal
standing
or our record
and not with us personally."
Do you get that?
When a criminal is pardoned by the legal
process of law,
his standing before the law is changed,
but his character is unaffected
at first.
Justification is credited righteousness
unto you.
All right? So, that should make some
more sense now.
Here's what most people need to hear,
the area that they forget to understand.
And it's a direct quote from this book,
His Robe or Mine.
"There is nothing that time, experience,
talent, or effort can add to this
marvelous gift
because Christ achieved a perfect
character that is his unspeakable gift
to us."
It also goes on to say, "There is a
work, of course,
a most trying and painstaking work
of submitting our will to his and doing
what he commands.
However,
we must keep in mind that only God can
do his part of the work, and only man
can do the other part of the work that
he's meant to do."
And of course, what this means
is that, like we were talking about
before, you got to clean up your life.
You got to give your will to him and
follow the commands of the Bible.
And what he's going to do with his
spirit given to you when you ask help
like help help me get over this
addiction. Help me give up smoking,
drinking, fornication,
um
cussing,
eating bad,
overeating. Like it actually stems to a
lot of your areas of life
that even speeding,
any way that you ask him to help, his
spirit will help you when you submit
your will and you ask for help and you
take his gift of salvation,
you still have to
submit to the spirit helping you become
an overcomer in these ways.
But
when you submit and you do what you're
supposed to, it's kind of like
a teacher can say, "Yes, they are giving
their all.
They are doing this work and their faith
is producing works. Their homework, in
other words, is producing a good grade."
Yes, I understand that some of that is
works, but you have to have fruit.
The Bible tells you to look at people's
fruits, but
their fruits will tell you whether they
have the Holy Spirit or not.
And so,
your life will bear fruit. I no longer
drink anymore. I no longer cuss. I no
longer lose my temper. I no longer have
this and that. Now I am
better, but it doesn't mean that you
have attained perfection.
It just means
as you submit to the Holy Spirit and he
works in you, it's kind of like holding
hands
with God.
He was seriously, you're holding on to
his strength
and he's perfecting your character along
the way, the whole way. It's more like
if someone grabs my hand and we're just
holding each other steady
the whole time.
One step at a time.
And that's beautiful if you think about
it. He is truly strengthening you and
lifting you up and you're holding on to
him.
And so,
we have to think about it like that
because that's truly how it works.
Now, sanctification, the other term I
used,
is imparted righteousness of Christ,
which is the imparted righteousness of
Christ is the peace we get in doing so.
All right.
So,
it'll get clarified a little deeper,
but here's another quote from the book.
"Therefore, being justified by faith,
we have peace with God through our Lord
Jesus Christ. That's Romans 5:1.
But it goes on to say, Jesus not only
justifies me, but also makes peace
between me,
the sinner,
and God, my maker, whom I have been
rebelling against and offended.
The believer is not called upon to make
his peace with God himself.
He never has, nor ever can do this
for himself.
He is to accept Christ as his peace.
For with Christ is God and peace.
The carnal mind is enmity
against God.
For it is not subject to the law of God,
neither indeed can it be.
We know that verse, right? And they're
applying that verse to it.
So then, they say,
they are
that are in the flesh cannot please him.
Okay, so if you continue to say, yes,
I'm a Christian, but you know, I still
I'm just saying, according to the Bible,
it says we have a soul and a mind, so I
still drink, I still
smoke, I still do drugs, I still sleep
around, I still eat this or that.
Um the Bible says not to, and
I lie still.
Then,
it is directly saying that when you're
holding on to sins in your life,
I have play these video games,
um
I have this idol in my life that comes
before Christ every day.
When you still have those things that
come before him,
you are living according to the flesh,
and
you cannot please him.
So the thing is,
we need to give those things up. We have
to give them up to him, and he is he's
going to perfect us. As we hold on to
him, he strengthens us,
he strengthens us, we can overcome all
of it, and overcomers go to heaven. That
is another verse I think I should look
up here.
For whosoever is born of God overcometh
the world. And this is the victory that
overcometh the world, even our faith. So
that's how you see it. We cannot live
according to the flesh of this world and
sinful nature.
We have to be born of God and overcome
the world,
and that is the victory
of living out our faith is what it's
basically saying.
And here it says also, Revelation 21:7,
he that overcometh shall inherit all
things.
And I will be his God, and he shall be
my son,
says the Lord.
All right, here's another promise in
Revelation 2:26,
and he that overcometh and keepeth my
works unto the end,
to him will I give power over the
nations.
Here we are,
to Revelation 3:21,
to him that overcometh will I grant to
sit with me in my throne,
even as I also overcame, and I'm set
down with my father in his throne.
Wow, that's good.
All right.
So I think that proves that point pretty
well.
Now we have to continue to understand
this deeper.
You see, it's not because you checked
every box,
not because you remembered every sin
that you need to confess before him, and
it's not because you met everyone's
standard that they're holding you to.
It's not because you
it's only because
only because you trusted, believed,
and followed
God and his commands. You overcame
the way he overcame,
and that is in resisting the devil,
turning away from temptation, and
becoming perfected and refined,
or sanctified,
by
his work in you,
and giving into that work happening
inside of you.
Now, again, some would argue that means
that no change has actually have to
happen inside of me. I don't have to do
anything. I am perfect, I am sa- saved,
I'll be in heaven. Like, there's nothing
I need to do.
No,
because
it does mean that changes need to occur
inside of you. Something has to be real
inside of you. It can't just be
hearers of the word and not doers again,
and works without faith,
or vice versa, faith out works. You have
to have both going on here, which means
your faith has to produce
fruits.
I already said that.
But the real thing is when it comes from
a genuine heart, also.
Some people,
it says in the Bible, will carry out
this
because they're just
don't want to go to hell.
So they're out of fear.
They don't really love God, they don't
really love what he has for you and how
he operates, or
his laws, but they just want to keep all
those things so that they may
avoid going to hell.
And the thing is,
you have to have a genuine heart,
because that is what transforms you
completely.
A full conversion in Christ,
where your heart latches on, and that
holding on to Christ as his spirit works
inside of you to perfect you and become
an overcomer of this world,
the way he was,
occurs.
And you begin to walk differently. You
begin to hate sin and resist temptation
like he did.
You begin to align with God's will
and who he is.
But here's the key, that transformation
is the fruit, again, this fruit of a
converted believer,
not the requirement for acceptance.
Some people try to come
made perfect already to God. No, give
your life to him, and he's the one who's
supposed to perfect you.
It is not the requirement
of being perfect first before accepting
Christ.
And this is again where a lot of people
get trapped, because they start
trying,
as they begin to give their life to God,
and they see other people doing it
around them, unfortunately,
they start realizing it is like a
checklist, or it's a lot of things you
have to do, but they're like, I'm going
to do it just so I can get there.
And it becomes
performed righteousness.
And it's when you start doing things
just to meet a standard,
to do what others do,
or to feel safe, or to prove something,
or just to keep the status quo that
you're seeing around you.
If it's not coming from a genuine
motive, and that would be
I'm going to extend this, cuz a lot of
people probably don't like it that I'm
going to extend this.
But that would include that if you are
supposed to
I don't know, be on the
the board for something every Sabbath
for like a year,
that if you start feeling like it's work
and you're hating every moment of it,
you no longer have pure genuine motives
coming from your heart,
he knows that you no longer feel that
way about coming from your heart the
right way,
you are deceiving yourself that you are
serving God.
And that's where a lot of people who are
dedicating too much time,
um
not focusing on their personal life,
they get service,
serving the church, doing acts of
service for others, um signing up for
too many things,
and so on. They think that that is what
your true Christian walk looks like.
It's not. That is actually can crowd out
your entire life, your full life with
Christ, where you actually know who he
is,
and that he knows you, and he cares
personally about you,
and that you're doing it because you
truly have a
true heart
of
conviction and genuineness towards him.
So if it's not coming from a genuine
motive, it's not truth.
It's called performance.
And anything done without sincerity,
without real conviction, isn't
righteousness.
It's a form of pretending.
I've seen so many people do this in
their churches.
And um
it's not healthy. And then they they
advise you to go sign up for several
positions yourself for you to become
burdened down,
and
perhaps fall into the same problem. And
sometimes you know that about yourself.
You know that if someone tries to get
you to do this,
you are going to completely have a bad
attitude while going in there and doing
it, and you're going to not feel it
genuinely as you give
that service to God.
And um
you need to protect yourself from that.
You should not do it.
Because the moment you realize here that
there is nothing
Well, let me backtrack.
So,
that pretending
is always going to be a form of
godliness then that you are faking while
other people think
you're upholding a standard and you act
like everything's fine and perfect in
your life,
so that's what they have to do, too. It
becomes a status quo that you're looking
all around you and going, "Well, that's
what they do, and that's what they do.
That's what That's what righteousness
must look like.
And being a good Christian in service to
my church or my brothers and sisters."
And so, even that is where we can stop
hanging our
expectations of each other on one
another and start taking it off. And I
literally feel sometimes like it's
taking huge weighted vests off of me as
I go, "No." You start learning how to
say no, also.
"No, I'm not going to be doing that. No,
you said I have to be there? Well,
for my stability, my sanity,
and my coping right now, and according
to what I feel in my heart to keep on
the same standard as God,
no, I can't do that right now, and I
won't be."
And so,
when we realize we have to stop that
pretending
to keep other people happy,
but be genuine with what we are
we know about ourselves and we feel
and
that our heart is not going to be in the
right place
or we are
faith is just being
um on knowledge and it's not about
caring it out in our lives and truly
having
fruits and works and actions that meet
it,
then we're not living the true life.
But we have to have some takeaways here.
There's nothing you can do to earn
salvation. We have to understand that.
Nothing.
So, when people are saying, "Oh, you
have to do this, you have to do that."
And "Oh, by the way, did you know you
can't have this and you can't have that
in your life?" Well,
they're adding to the Bible.
And the other thing is that
nothing others can pile onto you
actually secures your salvation, either.
All right?
And then you begin to realize
as you come to the end of all of this,
when you realize what God actually does
tell you.
>> [laughter]
>> And I hate to say this, I'm It's just
occurring to me right now.
His yoke is lighter than everyone else's
yoke that they're trying to put on you.
They're trying to like
put that bit in your mouth and throttle
you, and you know what I mean?
He's so much easier
to work with and work for than all the
expectations of other people.
And so, everything changes. You can let
people go. You can take off those heavy
weights they're putting on you of trying
to meet expectations as you go about
your walk with him.
And the pressure breaks.
The fear loosens.
There is joy.
There is peace.
And constant self-examination loses its
grip on your life. Yes, we need to be
kept accountable, and we have to examine
ourselves. I I believe in having a life
where you analyze yourself quite a lot
before Christ and having a transparent
life
with God.
But you don't have to seriously
hurt yourself by constantly
feeling guilt and shame
and trying to figure out what you've
done wrong
in your life.
And then, for most of us, like it gave
me, and I hope you realize this,
from what I'm saying, for the first time
you are not chasing perfection.
And you can cast off
these big, heavy
like boulders others have been putting
on your back
as you try to trek up the mountain of
the kingdom of God
towards Christ.
And finally, you're resting. You have
the peace. You take all of it off. You
kind of sigh
>> [sighs]
>> with such relief.
And you're resting in the one who
already is perfect
and who has you every step of that way
up that mountain, if you want to call it
a mountain,
to the kingdom of God in your walk on
the straight and narrow path with him,
and he
loves you.
Yeah, you're not perfect, and he's
working on you, and you do need to reach
the overcoming state,
which he attained that he wants for you,
too.
But
he has you in the palm of his hand. I
hope that's helpful to to people
to understand when you hear this,
he has you there,
he loves you,
he's working on you.
Just take his hand and walk
and submit. And when you have these
temptations, turn away from them. Resist
the devil. Overcome
by taking his hand and holding onto it
with everything you have
and giving in.
But that peace, as you begin to
submit and shoulder into his support,
it becomes beautiful.
For me, it brought tears to my eyes as I
realized I was finally free.
Free of what other people think.
Free of what other people are trying to
put on me all the time.
And free to say no
because they are sometimes just
cluttering up my life with more things
that I don't need in my life. I don't
need more complications. We We don't
need more weight from each other and
judgments and
in some ways persecution from each
other.
When we hold on, we see God is already
perfect. He is our perfection,
and that price is going to be what gets
us in.
You can finally stop listening
to the extra voices that Satan likes to
put in your head, even,
and pressure he likes to put on you from
other people.
And you can just have a clear conviction
and peace and happiness walking
next to Christ
and after Christ on that straight and
narrow path as he leads you.
And from that place,
from that place,
there's
where real obedience come comes from.
That's where real change happens in you.
And that's where truth actually takes
root within you.
It is able to solidify you,
stabilize you,
and strengthen you as you go about your
daily walk.
It's not forced anymore.
It's not performed.
It's not about saying yes to everything.
And it's not driven by fear anymore.
But it's completely real.
And that is what I want people to
understand. There are so many
misconceptions. There are so many things
being preached
in different
denominations and different churches
that puts more weight on you. It just
makes it harder what they're saying.
It's not helpful.
And it is it's misconstrued, and I'm
hoping this really
really did bless you guys and help
clarify quite a lot of how
we stand before God and how he sees us
and how we seriously lean into him and
cooperate with him
for that perfection to be attained
and how he makes us overcomers, but his
perfect life is truly what covers us.
But because we are both overcomers, him
and hopefully all of us,
we seriously do get to share his throne
in heaven.
He puts those robes on us. He puts those
crowns on us.
And we can truly say, just in case you
didn't know,
the angels have not been through the
overcoming that we have been through,
and we will have that knowledge
that they don't have
that Christ shares in
that we can say,
"We are overcomers."
Through the power of the lamb and the
blood of the lamb.
And we share that with Christ. It's such
a special connection and bond that I
don't want other people
to miss out on.
And uh
yeah.
It's been weighing down heavily on me
for quite a while as I grew up
and did grow up as a child. It's It was
always more and more things people were
forcing onto me.
And I am just learning
unfortunately.
And I want to give it to you guys
freedom.
Not freedom to keep sinning, but freedom
to really understand what
God's gift looks like and how it works.
And how his peace will be given to you
as you submit
and surrender and this
refining happens.
So,
enough of that.
I um
I hope this blesses. Thank you guys for
tuning in.
And we love you guys.
So, have a good night.
All right.
Oh, before I stop, there is of course
>> [laughter]
>> I got straight into it.
Forgot that um if you guys enjoyed that
and you are new to our channel perhaps
or you are
here and you've loved our channel, you
can go ahead and use several methods to
support our channel such as Cash App,
Venmo, Zelle, and PayPal.
And we appreciate every gift, every
thing that you guys
um support us with.
So, thank you guys so much. And we also
have merchandise which you can get and
that's on candidtruth.org.
Um go to shop.
And there we are.
There is the full spiel.
Again, have a good night, you guys.
Goodbye.